Oh Jennifer lópez's families in the
holiday spirit look at her son Max doing
a little boogie right there oh he gets
it from his mama I love that him along
with Alex Rodriguez's daughter Natasha
and don't worry JLo and a rod also
helped trim the tree now jennifer has a
new movie just in time for the holidays
it's called second act with her bestie
Leah Remini and boy did we have a lot of
fun just talking amongst us girls y'all
been girlfriends for so long do you
remember the first time you met it was
one of those instant chemistry folks
right where you just feel like I love
this person well I was friends with Mark
Anthony and so we and then he started
dating Jennifer and he was doing a film
man on fire I watched the premiere
hoping that she was gonna be ugly in
real life and then I was like got closer
I was like oh damn there's a lot of
light right here and she looks really
pretty and then I'm like I I even said
that I even said dammit why are you so
pretty and he laughed and I was like oh
I hope she's done missing a finger
something you know he's something I'm
gonna find something and I didn't make
no mistake these two are totally bribed
or died but does leah approve of JLo's
man a rod I think when you see people
happy and complete that's all that
matters that's all you want for your
exact Lee you only want to see him happy
assets cream those jeans by the way
again yeah I'm not a piece of meat in
second act
Jennifer's guys played by Milo
Ventimiglia we all know he's
good-looking yeah he on the eyes was
that the first thing that said okay this
is why this is who you want oh it was
his heart I'm watching him on this is us
I was just like this guy has so much
heart and passion and I just had it set
in my head the same way I had it said
that Leah needed to do this was a [ __ ]
who's the champ let's go
who's the chant on this panel would you
stop her for real yeah yeah yeah she
cracked me back a good one but you know
that's Latin right yeah
action and she added a nice like okay
but her your things me Olli it makes me
laugh every time because it like your
face in real life would you like
[Music]